hello everyone today we are going to
take a look at a video titled how
america funded ukraine's neo-nazis by
the channel called the gravel institute
and just who are the gravel institute
we're building the infrastructure to
beat right-wing propaganda outlets like
prageru on their own turf with concise
five-minute videos from authoritarian
presenters from bernie sanders to
chelsea manning were pushing
non-traditional audiences to the left
and to fight a behemoth like prager with
huge ad budgets and millions of
subscribers we need you on board join us
so that's nice they're trying to be a
leftist counterweight to prageru a
massive right-wing disinformation
channel fighting this information online
is especially important nowadays in
light of the invasion of ukraine russia
has been pumping out an ungodly amount
of lies and misinformation outdoing
outlets even like prageru by an order of
magnitude and prageru is no small player
either they really put it all out there
they're aggressively pro-capitalism
anti-palestinian anti-big government aka
social programs for non-whites and
anti-taxing high income earners and they
also have a few things to say about
black crime the left antifa and so on
and so forth but the secret to prageru's
success is not found in their political
positions in fact if you laid them out
there most people would see them for the
lunatics that they are the secret to
prageru's success lies in their
presentation lies pun intended i guess
it might not come as a surprise to most
of you but prager university is not here
to educate people contrary to their
description they are here to push a
specific set of socio-economic and
political agendas and they rarely do
this through outright lies rather they
twist information leave out or
de-emphasize inconvenient facts
over-emphasize convenient facts mislead
you with disingenuous presentation of
statistics and they use loaded emotional
language to prime you for their
conclusions among other things all in
service of furthering their agenda and
youtubers like shawn or vosh already did
a number of excellent takedowns of their
lives which you should definitely check
out afterwards now all these being said
prageru doesn't have to try too hard to
disseminate misinformation this is due
to their target audience namely u.s
conservatives a group whose world views
are based mostly on emotionally held
positions and then those conservatives
go out looking for justifications for
their feelings which prageru is happy to
provide so as a conservative if you
simply hate black people let's say you
won't be looking at the history of
systemic discrimination the lingering
effects of redlining jim crow slavery
and so on to try and contextualize and
perhaps eliminate your bias instead
you'll be watching police go where the
crime is by prageru which confirms your
biases of black people being violent
criminal savages who don't work and
abandon their children
in the 75 largest u.s counties about 60
percent of robbery and murder defendants
are black even though blacks comprise
only 15 percent of the population in
those counties
in new york city blacks make up 73
percent of all shooting victims though
they are 23 percent of the city's
population
in chicago in 2016 there were three
hundred shooting victims almost all
black
among the two dozen victims under the
age of twelve
was a three-year-old shot on father's
day who was now paralyzed for life and a
ten-year-old shot on labor day whose
pancreas and spleen were ripped apart in
short prageru has it rather easy
preaching to a friendly audience
preconditioned by the conservative media
industrial complex having suppressed
their critical thinking skills as much
as possible so they will accept any
bogus graph half truth and outright
falsehood as the capital t truth in
service of the conservative agenda for
prageru it would be much more difficult
to propagandize to a leftist audience
since that group is generally more aware
of history and socioeconomics by and
large have better critical thinking
skills and would be more prone to
calling them out on their [ __ ] if we
had a stalinist break or hue let's say
they would need to be much more subtle
using every opportunity for plausible
deniability phrasing statements and
questions neutrally but in a very
leading context and so on and so forth
otherwise their core audience would be
made up of people with the following
characteristics the alpha and omega of
their worldview being us bad the
fetishization of the soviet union and
thinking it achieved communism or was
progressing towards it despite reality
the bizarre reverence of countries that
are opposed to the us like north korea
cuba syria and so on just because
they're opposed to the us and branding
all their opponents as fascists to
justify every action against them and
then denying the actual fascist actions
of the governments they support in
common parlance we call these people
tankies the name comes from the soviet
union rolling tanks into countries to
crack down on anti-soviet protests you
might have guessed but these people
aren't leftists they are nazis painted
red for all intents and purposes and so
the gravel institute let's take a look
at this video of theirs in the spirit of
sean the video is linked in the
description feel free to check it out to
make sure i'm not misrepresenting any of
their points and just to clarify this
video came out 6 days before the russian
invasion of ukraine
[Music]
ukraine ukraine ukraine ukraine ukraine
ukraine you've probably heard about that
country a lot
for the last few years ukraine has been
one of the most important conflict
points in the world
it's the site of a proxy war between
russia and the united states okay so
we're 20 seconds in and we already have
a problem ukraine is the site of a proxy
war between russia and the united states
a proxy war is when two larger powers
battle each other through smaller local
forces that they control or heavily
influence all in service of their
geopolitical interests but in the case
of ukraine this is incorrect the
ukrainian government is supported by the
us and other western nations but they
are by no means proxies of the us they
are a democratic government that came
under attack by actual russian proxies
and the russian army itself at which
point they asked for help and they got
it just because ukraine defending itself
against russian imperialism coincides
with western interests of not having
russian imperialism doesn't make this
conflict a proxy war so right off the
bat this is a serious misrepresentation
by the greville institute imagine if
czechoslovakia resisted the nazis as the
latter annexed the sunnaten land and
they got military equipment and training
from the uk or something would that make
it a proxy war between germany and the
uk of course not that would be
ridiculous but it would be a great
opportunity for nazi propaganda to try
and discredit czechoslovakia and justify
the invasion saying how czechs are just
pawns of the english and how their
resistance is bringing war to europe for
no good reason if the czechs just
stopped fighting us there would be peace
we had a vote in the southern and people
do want to join us so it's all good
right
russia could launch an attack on ukraine
any day now we are ready and all of nato
is ready but it's also a place most
people don't really know a lot about so
the story we hear about ukraine's
history and its conflict today has very
little relationship to reality
i'm going to tell you a story about
modern ukraine but this is also a story
about america and how american money and
weapons ended up in the hands of these
guys
the neo-nazis and ultra-nationalists of
ukraine's far right
wait did you catch that they should move
the goal posts how america funded
ukraine's neo-nazis versus how american
money and weapons ended up in the hands
of these guys those two statements have
very different implications the first
implies a deliberate effort from the u.s
to army ukrainian nazis while the second
suggests that army neo-nazis wasn't the
intention only an unfortunate side
effect and slimy rhetorical tricks like
these should be familiar to anyone who
has ever watched prager university think
about the even greater number of
palestinians who are now homeless in
gaza because hamas choose to hide
weapons in residential buildings
and when naive american and european
ngos offer millions to rebuild gaza who
do you think will get that money it
won't be you the people who really
deserve it
and need it
it will be the leaders of the hamas gang
and their friends who will add new rooms
to their fancy villas
rather than rebuilt homes purchase
coronavirus vaccines or provide social
services for their people and the peace
you so deserve the peace which could
have been possible when israel withdrew
entirely from the gaza strip in 2005
will be even further out of reach well
it looks like all that aid we're sending
to palestinians is ending up in the
hands of extremists therefore we should
stop giving money and aid to
palestinians and just let israel invade
the gaza strip in a special need for
operation where they de-islamistize the
area in order to finally bring peace to
the middle east one could say though for
some reason i highly doubt gravel
institute would agree with stopping aid
to palestinians and funny how that works
let's start in 1991 when ukraine became
fully independent from the soviet union
and independence was tough
after the fall of communism the
economies of post-soviet republics were
falling apart
minor point here but while in common
parlance we do refer to the end of the
soviet union as the fall of communism
that is incorrect the soviet union was a
state capitalist oligarchy at best and
never even came close to abolishing the
state currency or social classes as in
communism i expect a channel fencing
itself as leftist to be more precise
with its leftist terms
state institutions were being hollowed
out a so-called gangster capitalism was
becoming dominant so in the 1990s
ukraine's economy and quality of life
collapsed and it's never really gotten
better
adjusted for inflation ukraine's gdp per
capita was higher in 1990 than it was in
2020.
health outcomes are abysmal in 2019 the
life expectancy of ukrainian men was
lower than in syria iraq and north korea
first off i'm glad gravel institute has
such unwavering trust in demographic
data provided by the syrian and north
korean governments very noble second
according to the world bank data they
cite male life expectancy in ukraine is
currently at an all-time high even with
an ongoing war inside the country where
lots of men tend to die so by their
metric male life expectancy should be a
relative success story not abysmal as
they put it for a strange inconsistency
in their rhetoric third the choice of
countries on the graph you might think
in comparison with poland russia or
hungary or other eastern european
countries would be more informative
since they are similar in terms of
demographics geopolitics history and so
on why bring up these random countries
from different corners of the world why
not eastern european countries well
because if you put those on the graph
you get this countries that used to be
in the soviet sphere of influence but
broke away very early and fully
integrated into the west have much
higher life expectancies than ukraine or
even russia and then some cynical person
might come along and point out how being
aligned with the decaying russian empire
produces significantly worse outcomes
than being aligned with the west such
nuance of course did not make it into
gravel institute's video coincidentally
theirs would be the type of rhetoric you
would use if you wanted to imply that
aligning with the west doesn't make
things better for the people also look
at these other countries that aren't
aligned with the west that are doing
better right in the next section gravel
institute describes the roots of
ukrainian neonatism like so and as
quality of life collapsed nationalism
flourished
some people turned to extremist politics
and that was partly because ukrainian
nationalism
formed an opposition to the soviet union
tended to have a strongly right-wing
flavor
to understand that we have to look at a
crucial figure in ukrainian nationalist
history a guy named stephane bandera
you see in the 1930s and 40s bandera won
a ukrainian independence from poland and
the soviet union so when the nazis
invaded bandera allied with them his
followers massacred huge numbers of
poles and jews
but in spite of this legacy bandera is
still viewed as a hero in the west of
ukraine
they are slip on bandera streets museums
and monuments
in 2010 bandera was even named an
official hero of ukraine so in their
world this bandera guy did ethnic
cleansing while collaborating with the
nazis as he saw ukrainian independence
and he is revered to this day mostly in
the west of the country which is a
rather far-right region what gravel
institute conveniently omitted is that
the biggest resurgence of pro-bantera
sentiment happened after russia invaded
ukraine sure the far-right had a
presence even before and was also out to
protest during the maidan obviously but
the real push for decommunization and
the re-establishment of the ukrainian
national identity came after crimea was
stolen and when the ukrainian army was
already fighting a war in the east
against both russian proxies and actual
russian soldiers to go back to examples
from the east why do you think groups
like isis the taliban or al-qaeda gained
such prominence because a larger
imperialist power invaded their lands
which galvanized their support and
helped them rise to prominence this is
extremism 101 which i'm sure greville
institute would agree with why then do
they not extend this very simple concept
to ukraine because then it would be much
harder to fearmonger about ukrainian
nazis in service of the underlying goal
which is to pander to an audience that
only wants to hear america bad oh sorry
i got ahead of myself there moving on
but bandera is hated in the east where
soviet identity was historically a lot
stronger
and that east-west divide was a big
fracture within ukraine
in western ukraine there was more stress
on a specifically ukrainian identity
closer to europe in eastern ukraine
meanwhile people were more likely to
stress their historic ties to russia and
the russian language
fast forward to 2010 when ukraine
elected a relatively pro-russian
politician named victor yanukovych as
its president with strong support from
voters in the east
yanukovych pursued a regionalist and
russia-friendly agenda which angered
people in the west so the east-west
divide in ukraine the west is more
pro-european while the east is more
pro-russian and the latter helped to
like victorinokovic none of this is
false on the surface however calling
victorianukovic a relatively pro-russian
politician is a way to de-emphasize
ionic which is staunchly for russian
politics and i noticed how gravel
institute leaves out the inconvenient
fact that yanukovych imprisoned his
pro-western opponent yulia kimochenko
right after he got elected in 2010 also
that he stole the election in 2004 when
ukrainians needed the orange revolution
to force a rerun which yanukovych then
lost and these instances of twisting
information using loaded language and
disingenuous presentation only get more
numerous as the video goes on like this
part right here
and in 2013 yanukovych announced that he
was suspending discussions on ukrainian
integration with europe
that decision sparked a protest movement
centered in kiev called yura maidan
after the maidan square where it took
place
in kiev thousands of ukrainians continue
to protest against the government's
decision to hold off on signing a deal
with the eu and i want you to consider
this hundreds of thousands of people out
on the streets tens of thousands of
flags and signs and the three they show
us are all bundler related with his
portrait and the red and black flag this
was a conscious choice they could have
easily found footage of protesters from
a massive crowd like this without
bundler-related items but instead they
went out of their way to find footage
that specifically contains farat
adjacent imagery and they did this to
lay some groundwork for the next section
which is what i would call a mask off
moment let's give it a watch in the west
yura maidan was seen as a peaceful
pro-democracy movement and most
participants really were ordinary people
who were angry at the government
but as the protests grew encouraged by a
harsh repression from the police and a
brutal sniper attack that killed dozens
of protesters and police alike
a new more sinister element emerged and
began to hijack the movement the
ultranationalist came on the scene
it was often the nationalists who were
the loudest and the most violent
a group calling itself the right sector
is perhaps the largest its members can
be seen marching around kiev in columns
of about a dozen
groups like the quote right sector the
ultra-nationalist vobota party
originally called the social national
party of ukraine try turning those words
around
acted as a small but influential
organized minority within the protests
and those extremists played an important
role in exacerbating the protests by
encouraging violence and more radical
rhetoric
there are allegations that the sniper
attack was actually orchestrated by the
right sector and its co-conspirators
okay so what have we just listened to
here are the main claims so their first
point about protesters being ordinary
people is correct point number two is a
lie however and unfortunately for gravel
institute i recognized the footage they
used see in preparation for my giant
video essay about ukraine i saw a lot of
videos about police violence during the
minor protests and i also came across
the footage greville institute is
showing here or rather the two versions
of it one shown by western news outlets
and the other shown by russia today now
shortly after the russian invasion of
ukraine rt was banned from youtube but
thankfully i downloaded their video back
then it's the same footage as in western
media with an important difference they
cut out the part where the police start
running at protesters with guns and
opening fire and only show the part
where protesters some also armed return
fire at the police who are then forced
to retreat here's footage from radio's
vobody in contrast showing what actually
happened namely how it was the police
charging at protesters and opening fire
at them and if we skip towards the end
of the video we arrived to the footage
rt had shown and through rt
the grabble institute and i even
screenshotted some indicative comments
from under rt's video back then which i
ended up not using for my ukraine video
essay they're being fired at with live
ammo what are they supposed to do i am
surprised no police officer has flipped
yet and fired a full clip in a crowd i
see retreating policemen who attempt to
save their motionless colleague how was
he injured and fired in self-defense not
at peaceful protesters but an aggressive
mob they saved their lives we can see
that the peaceful protesters shooting at
police and police escape i am surprised
why have they waited so long so these
comments were under a video titled
police firing live ammo in kiev clashes
these are the opinions rt is trying to
conjure up with their deceptively cut
footage which is the same thing gravel
institute did here as they talk about
allegations that it was the far right
that did the shooting while showing you
injured and retreating police officers
disingenuously cut from a video where
police attacked first the gravel
institute is lying to you here by
omission and how about that article they
show claiming that the shooting was done
not by police but by the right sector
and its co-conspirators here it is on
dnation.com titled america's collusion
with neo-nazis written by stephen f
cohen published on the 2nd of may 2018.
here's the paragraph shown by the gravel
institute that these snipers who killed
scores of protesters and policemen on
kia's maiden square in february 2014
thereby triggering a quote-unquote
democratic revolution that overthrew the
elected president viktor yanukovych and
brought to power a virulent anti-russian
pro-american regime it was neither
democratic nor a revolution but a
violent coup unfolding in the streets
with high-level support were not sent by
yanukovych as is still widely reported
but instead almost certainly
by the neo-fascist organization right
sector and its co-conspirators
[Music]
the sniper attack was almost certainly
done by ukrainian neo-fascists source
trust me bro i'm stephen f cohen or was
who spent the last decade doing pro
protein apologia and was a frequent
guest on russia today and i did find
this article about him in the new york
magazine titled the pathetic lives of
putin's american dupes written in 2014
around the time of russia's annexation
of crimea a tragically large number of
left-wing westerners in the 20th century
deluded themselves about the horrors of
soviet communism as awful and
unforgivable as it was the process by
which they made themselves into dukes
was at least explicable they loved
socialism and one country in the world
was implementing socialism so they
persuaded themselves and for a while it
was working today's russia dupes are a
smaller more pathetic lot above all they
are just plain weirder because they lack
a clear ideological motive for their
stoogery soviet russia not only
commanded a vast propaganda network but
embodied a doctrine with international
appeal and which had originated outside
of russia vladimir putin's russia
follows no model except russian
nationalism to the extent it employs a
non-nationalist philosophy its main idea
is that gays have weakened europe and
yet the dupes still come the most
prominent intellectual apologist for
putin is stephane f cohen princeton
professor russologist for the left-wing
nation cohen is a septuagenarian
old-school leftist who has carried on
the mental habits of decades of
anti-anti-communism seamlessly into a
new career of anti-anti-putinism the
cohen method is to pick away at every
indictment of the russian regime without
directly associating himself with his
various atrocities is pushing
persecuting gays well cohen wants you to
know that various ukrainian nationalists
dislike gays too and also barack obama's
claim to snub sochi because of gay
rights is probably not on the level he's
pushing bullying and killing journalists
that's going every time a journalist
breaks a leg they say the kremlin did it
accidents happen so stefan fcowen was
your average kremlin stooge with
significant ties to russian state
propaganda and he said that the modern
shootings were almost certainly done by
ukrainian nazis the gravel institute
doesn't mention cohen's name or
background in their video they just
throw out that screenshot and read out
half a sentence i suppose they really
wanted to de-emphasize cohen here if
they wanted to be unbiased they could
have said stephen cohen pro-russian
academic and frequent guest on rt
alleges that the sniper attacks were
done by ukrainian neo-fascists but
instead we get a fleeting mention of a
wild claim in an article without sources
and the problem with this is that there
can be plenty of allegations made about
everything there are allegations that
george bush did 9 11 there are
allegations about a ring of
democrat-linked satanic pedophile cabal
operating out of epidemia in washington
there are allegations about george soros
wanting to import brown people into
europe to commit white genocide a pick
your favorite really there are
allegations is the rallying cry of
conspiracy theorists and the euphemism
for i have no evidence but to go back to
the gravel institute's points they even
managed to contradict themselves on one
hand the far right people were hijacking
the movement meaning they were taking
over on the other hand they were only a
small but influential group with a dozen
of them marching around at a time and
they merely helped exacerbate protests
by encouraging violence and extreme
rhetoric meaning they weren't taking
over only they had a relatively outsized
presence and their saber rattling
inspired more violence here and there so
which is it then did they hijack the
protests or were they just a loud
minority who said mean things and got
into more scuffles why are you putting
these mostly neutral statements in such
a leading contact scriptural institute
in a way that all tankies and pro
between lunatics can immediately infer
what you're saying while you can still
claim plausible deniability
by early 2014 the government lost the
ability to control a protest
in a rapidly evolving political crisis
president yanukovych has been voted out
by parliament
forced to leave kiev
and the us-recognized interim government
that replaced him had a significant
far-right faction
the deputy prime minister the minister
of defense and others were all from that
far-right party spaboda so the interim
government had a significant far-right
faction and four ministers came from the
far rights for buddha party this is true
however gravel institute is conveniently
leaving out a number of relevant things
here the four people on the picture are
aleksander sikh igor tanyuk andrey
moknik and ihorshawaika and there are a
couple of things to mention here first
as global institute says they were only
part of the interim government that
means they were all gone by the 12th of
november 2014 except for ihortanyuk who
left much earlier having spent a grand
total of 26 days in his position also
alexander sikh was one of three deputy
prime ministers with the other two not
being from slovoda second none of these
people were succeeded by other swabata
politicians third on the elections in
october 2014 this football party had
lost 31 seats out of their original 37
having gotten only 4.71 of the national
vote the right sector also ran and won a
single seed with 1.8 percent of the
national vote so if gravel institute
wanted to be honest here they could have
said something like this the fall ride
had a presence within the interim
government having achieved four
ministerial positions from march till
november 2014 except for the defense
minister who was removed after less than
a month they weren't succeeded by other
far-right politicians however and
svoboda lost the majority of its seats
during the october election while the
right sector only won a single seat it
doesn't sound so scary or dramatic when
you put it that way does it but once
again the goal of gravel institute here
is not to tell you what happened but to
push a specific pro-russian narrative in
their world the entire government was
full of nazis
and this led to backlash in the east
because eastern ukrainians were
horrified at what they saw as a
far-right seizure of power
with veneration of bandera an
elimination of equal recognition for
languages like russian service industry
workers have since january been obliged
to talk to customers in ukrainian unless
clients specifically ask the switch if i
work pay my employees salaries and my
taxes it's none of your bloody business
which language
and here i want to briefly consider
manipulation through word choice the u.s
recognized interim government was full
of far-right people the easterners were
horrified at what they saw was a
far-right seizure of power the
elimination of russian is an equal
language the use of emotional loaded
language serves to feed into the
overarching narrative that the evil u.s
is funding evil ukrainian nazis and the
poor russian-speaking ukrainians are
very scared funny enough this rhetorical
trick is once again familiar to me from
channels like prageru
this is the reality that police
commanders in urban areas face every day
and every day they get calls from law
abiding citizens in high crime
neighborhoods
begging for assistance gravel institute
also doesn't mention that russia tends
to actively use the russian language as
a geopolitical weapon russian speakers
to russia is like oil to america if you
have too much of it sooner or later
their army shows up on your borders to
liberate your country also i love how
they put the story of the service
workers next to the smogwater image the
government was usurped by evil
anti-russian nazis it is implied who
have instituted the draconian measure of
service workers in ukraine having to
engage customers in ukrainian unless the
customer asks for russian in which case
it's fine okay but in the next segment
they go even further in the form of
trivializing actual russian imperialism
through euphemisms anti-government
protests broke out across the east
in the eastern peninsula of crimea
people were furious many of them talked
about joining russia so the russian
government saw an opportunity they
wanted to encourage a surge of russian
nationalism for its own benefit
so russia annexed crimea and held a
disputed referendum to legitimize the
decision the russian government wanted
to encourage a surge of russian
nationalism for their own benefit so
russia annexed crimea and held a
disputed referendum to legitimize the
decision and isn't that amazing at least
they use the word annex there so it's
only 99 reprehensible but hey if that's
the game we're playing let's roll nazi
germany wanted to encourage a surge of
german nationalism for their own benefit
so they annexed the sudetenland and held
a disputed referendum to legitimize the
decision i'm surprised the greville
institute would try to trivialize
russian imperialism so openly it's
almost like they and their audience only
have a problem with imperialism when
it's the us doing it almost
as many as 95.5
of the electorate in crimea have voted
to join russia
we are going back home crimea is in
russia
by the way this 95.5 result is [ __ ]
we know this because as i've mentioned
in my original ukraine video a russian
state agency accidentally posted the
real results according to them the real
result was about 50 to 60 voting for
joining russia with a turnout of about
40 percent in a referendum on the
russian military occupation where the
two choices were yes and yes but later
and where the choice of remaining part
of ukraine was not on the ballot the
gravel institute doesn't mention any of
these details instead they take all
these lies falsifications and fraud
committed by russia and stuff it neatly
under the phrase disputed referendum
energized by the annexation and
supported by russian arms and military
personnel the anti-government protests
became a full-blown secessionist
movement
eastern provinces like donetsk and
luhans held separatist referendums and
declared independence
the new government branded these
rebellions as quote terrorist actions
ukraine entered a civil war which was
also a proxy war with russia okay so
anti-government protests became
secession movements after they were
energized by the annexation of crimea
and were supported by the russian
military i'm glad they admit that at
least then luiz kaluwan's held
referendums declared independence and
the new ukrainian government declared
these quote-unquote terrorist actions
and so two things number one you don't
need to put terrorist actions into
quotation marks what they did was by
definition terrorist action whether or
not you consider it moral number two and
this is very much a recurring theme now
gravel institute left out an important
detail namely that at the time of the
independence referendums the war in
donbass had already been going on for at
least a month meanwhile gravel institute
makes it sound like the war happened
after the referendums so no wonder the
ukrainian government prints these as
terrorist actions they were fighting a
war with them at that point now you
might think i'm picking at minor points
here but consider the overall picture of
their painting if someone unfamiliar
with recent ukrainian history watches
this what narrative have they been given
so far ukraine collapsed in the 90s and
became a [ __ ] country this caused a
farad resurgence in the west and the
pro-russian people in the east were
afraid of this the far-right hijacked
the protest against the somewhat
pro-russian president and murdered
dozens of protesters after people chased
away the president the new government
had a significant neo-nazi presence
people in the east were afraid of this
so after russia took crimea they
declared independence which began a
civil war with the ukrainian government
branding them as terrorists and would
you look at that we have arrived at
official russian state propaganda this
is the narrative russia today tries to
sell people in the west and even though
gravel institute does say that the
russian military is involved they
present this in a context that makes
their involvement arguably justified you
know russia might have involved its
military in ukraine but they're
supporting russian-speaking people who
were horrified at what they saw was a
far-right seizure of power so of course
the russians would help them militarily
this is apologia it's also a lie as
we've discussed but after decades of
austerity and corruption the ukrainian
army was totally unable to fight
so a lot of the action fell instead to
the people who were the most violent the
ultranationalists
so a new paramilitary emerged it was
called the azov battalion
and unlike the official ukrainian
military
azole's volunteers were willing to go
the distance but azab wasn't just any
random organization it was a pretty
disturbing far-right group
it had come out of neo-nazi street gangs
that had been used as muscle by
ukrainian elites in the 90s and 2000s
azov members regularly sported tattoos
of swastikas their symbol was based on a
nazi emblem
their leader declared that their mission
was to quote lead the white races of the
world in a final crusade against the
semite-led intervention
subhumans
but azov's neo-nazism turned out not to
be such a huge concern to the ukrainian
government
because in 2014 a guy named arsene
avakov became interior minister in
charge of police and security and avakov
had been a long time patron of the
neo-nazi gangs
and when he was a regional governor he
used them as enforcers
so when he became interior minister
avakov had the azov battalion
incorporated into ukraine's national
guard so the ukrainian military was in
shambles as a war was going on in the
east fueled by russia in response the
ukrainian government turned to the ultra
nationalists to help beat back the enemy
then the minister of interior made the
ezo battalion officially part of the
national guard and my question here is
what else was the ukrainian government
was supposed to do the country was
falling apart the separatists were
spreading westward their military was in
shambles and among the few forces you
did have you didn't know who's going to
betray you for russia then comes a group
of highly motivated old financialists
with weapons training whose entire
worldview is predicated on fighting
russian invaders and whose allegiance is
unquestionably with ukraine and they
tell you give us weapons and support and
we'll get [ __ ] done what decision maker
would say no to that even if you hate
the far righters wouldn't sending them
to war mean many of them would die that
would be a win-win right you help hold
the russian offensives and you end up
with less ultra nationalists in the end
and the reason why they got integrated
into the national guard is because they
did get the job done they were effective
had high morale and could be trusted to
not switch sides at the end of the day
the azo battalion's rise to prominence
could have been avoided
if russia didn't invade ukraine in 2014
and 2022 it seems like this would be the
quick and easy solution to ukraine's
supposed nazi problem if we can agree
that groups like isis or the taliban
rose to prominence due to western
meddling why can't we then say that
groups like azov did so due to russian
meddling gravel institute spends the
next section of their video describing
how u.s military assistance ended up in
the hands of azo fighters once again in
somewhat of a contrast with the original
title of the video which suggests a
direct and deliberate effort from the
uss part or does it turns out as i was
making this video they changed the title
from how america funded ukraine's
neo-nazis to america russia and
ukraine's far right and they even had to
edit their description saying this video
is about american funding for the azole
battalion it explicitly condemns russian
propaganda that ukraine is a neo-nazi
country quote unquote we stand strongly
against russia's invasion and will be
publishing a video about the russian
oligarchy and the rise of putin they say
they condemn russian propaganda that
ukraine is a neo-nazi country
after having spent nearly 10 minutes
priming you for that exact conclusion
they say ukraine is still mired in a war
on its territory and the russian
government likes to use ukrainian
nationalists in its propaganda part of
its practice of painting all ukrainians
as nazis of course those claims aren't
really true but then they spend the rest
of the video telling you how it actually
is true but ukraine still does have a
serious and militarized neo-nazi problem
so since the 2014 uprising ukraine's far
right has become increasingly powerful
azov veterans have been given high
positions in the security services the
new ukrainian government even made it a
criminal offense to deny bandera's
heroism
and in 2021 the united states and
ukraine were the only two countries to
vote against a u.n resolution condemning
the glorification of nazism a climate of
impunity has developed around far-right
violence
attacks against roma and gay people go
unpunished
a 2018 report found that ukraine had
more incidents of anti-semitic hate
crimes than all other post-soviet
republics combined that last article
they show there is particularly
interesting report ukraine had more
anti-semitic incidents than all former
soviet countries combined on the jewish
telegraphic agency this report comes
from the israeli ministry for diaspora
affairs a striking exception in the
trend of decrease in anti-semitic
incidents in eastern europe was ukraine
where the number of recorded
anti-semitic attacks was doubled from
last year and surpassed the tally for
all the incidents reported throughout
the entire region combined the report
said so that sounds rather alarming
however further in the article you'll
find this bit in an article published
saturday on radio liberty a ukrainian
state historian dismissed the israeli
report as anti-ukrainian propaganda and
a researcher of anti-semitism from
ukraine said the israeli report was
flawed and amateurish the researcher
vihaslav likachev who is affiliated with
the vad association of jewish
communities and organizations of ukraine
suggested in the article that the
report's authors merely summed up the
incidents they found reported online in
a quote blatant lack of professionalism
and violation of all standards of hate
crime documentation which are guided by
professional monitoring groups both in
ukraine and in the world end of quote
gravel institute of course never
mentioned this bit but here i also found
this article on the jerusalem post body
sloshkin ukraine is least anti-semitic
country in central europe in addition to
serving as president of the jewish
confederation of ukraine loshkin is also
a vice president of the world jewish
congress and the eurasian jewish
congress and works intensively with the
european jewish community loshkin says
that today ukraine is regarded as the
least anti-semitic country in central
europe and is a much more open and
accepting society the relationship
between jews and ukrainians is very
tolerant and it is a safe country for
jews he says the ukrainian jewish
community is very active there are many
jewish organizations both religious and
non-religious there are jewish centers
jewish schools and kosher restaurants
and now there are even battle rabbis
fighting the russians i might add the
pew research center actually did a
survey in eastern europe asking
respondents if they would not be willing
to accept jews as citizens of their
country only five percent of ukrainians
agreed with this making them the most
tolerant country in the area in contrast
14 of russians wouldn't accept jews as
russian citizens so there you have it
ukraine is not exactly an anti-semitic
hell hole as the greville institute or
the russian government would want you to
think but it's not a coincidence that
the denultification of ukraine was the
primary excuse for russia's invasion
that's the reason why greville institute
had to edit the video's title by the way
do not make it too obvious that they're
shamelessly peddling russian state
propaganda while at the same time
insisting that they don't in the comment
section a user even pointed out the
glaring contradiction in their video the
explanation of the east west split is
useful but it seems odd to talk about
ukraine's far right without also talking
about russia's fall right the russians
aren't the defenders of leftist rebels
they are the gangster capitalists
mentioned earlier in the videos there's
arguments to be had about whether arming
the ukrainians is the correct approach
to this situation but the framing of the
arguments in this video makes it seem
like the russians are justified in
supporting rebels which is strange
considering the main pillar of this
video is about how america is not
justified in its support and gravel
institute actually responded to this
saying that's very true we focus on u.s
stuff just because we're based in the us
but we obviously don't support russian
aggression and imperialism in ukraine
we'll do a video about yanikovich
didoya's clan and gangster capitalism
akhmatov comes to mind in the future too
they obviously don't support russian
aggression and imperialism in ukraine
they say under their video justifying
ukrainian aggression and imperialism in
ukraine and their twitter record is
similarly checkered on the 22nd of
february two days before the russian
invasion they tweeted two things can be
true at once one russian aggression in
ukraine is absolutely unjustified and
should be condemned two american and
nato involvement has only made the
situation worse so once again trying to
both sides their way out of the
situation you know a local domestic
serial abuser is threatening to kill one
of his ex-girlfriends and loiters around
her house with a shotgun and then
greville institute comes along and
points out how what he's doing is
unjustified and should be condemned but
also how the local anti-domestic abuse
leak has only made things worse because
now the man feels unsafe because of them
and then when the russian invasion began
greville institute tweeted the following
the heroic efforts of anti-war
protesters in russia deserve the
unconditional support of the
international left also ordinary
russians and ukrainians do not want war
putin's invasion is an evil act that
will destroy the lives of innocent
ukrainians will plunge russia into
economic desperation and will bring the
world closer to the brink of nuclear
annihilation so that's nice at least
they're admitting that the invasion is
bad unlike a lot of their followers
underneath their tweets however there's
also this tweet from the 16th of
february remember a few days ago when
the media said that russia was going to
invade ukraine today whatever happened
to that now i won't find this tweet on
their page anymore because they deleted
it but people took screenshots so we get
to enjoy it even now so up until the
invasion gravel institute told the line
that russia invading ukraine is western
propaganda and then they had to
backtrack like crazy deleting tweets
changing the title of their video and
adding the following to the description
this is once again under a video
spreading russian propaganda that
ukraine is a neo-nazi country as
greville institute denied and both sides
the invasion threat so once again which
is it gravel institute you can play this
game forever because people will call
you out on it like i just did instead of
edited titles descriptions and
clarifications i would recommend
deleting this video altogether to find a
behemoth like prager with huge ad
budgets and millions of subscribers you
cannot really have content like this
published especially now when it puts
you in league with some of the most
reprehensible people out there you won't
be bringing anyone over to the left with
such content in fact you might actively
scare people away from leftism with this
gravel institute also never talked about
the fact that the pro-russian party in
ukraine has had far larger support than
the fall right and how the letter only
won a single seat in the 2019 elections
inconvenient details i suppose as an
aside one of the chairmen of the
pro-russian party in ukraine is viktor
medvedchuk vladimir putin's close
confidant who mysteriously disappeared
from the country at the start of the
russian invasion in february 2022 while
he was supposed to be in house arrest by
the way on corruption charges when
ukrainian authorities showed up to his
palace because of course he has one they
didn't find medvedchuk but they did find
an exact replicabe luxury pullman dining
car custom built on-site from scratch
with even a little platform built for it
the car features copious amounts of
luxury including a golden tea heater a
gilded toilet come with a golden butt
rinsing shower and otherwise all the
expensive decorational items you can
physically cram inside that space the
ukrainian railways wants to nationalize
the car by the way which i hope happens
it'll be the second largest lost format
by chook after his yacht because of
course he has one royal romance was
seized by croatian authorities on the
16th of march and this seems to be a
recurring theme with pro-russian
politicians doesn't it super yachts
gigantic palaces ludicrous luxury the
main difference between russia and
ukraine is that in ukraine these tend to
get seized by the democratic government
elected by the people they also seized
yanukovych's palace after they maidan
and turned it into the museum of
corruption for example you would think
supposed leftists would be in support of
a country where such things happen
regularly but they aren't because
supporting ukraine would mean indirectly
supporting the us and they can't do that
because u.s bad political philosophy
anyway thank you for watching this was
my video about the gravel institute and
their lovely video and do check out my
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and i'll be seeing you
next time